uh welcome to hannity by the way happy
veterans day and thank you to the brave
men and women
all that have served this country with
honor and distinction
and you give us our freedoms and
liberties and
we can never repay you and tonight we
honor you also tonight
we're going to break down all the
insanity the madness
that's going to unfold this week all the
hypocrisy you've got the
do nothing hypocritical socialist
democrats
everything they've got planned uh for
the week and frankly beyond
in the next 358 days or so until
election day if i could only get my
volume up here
somewhere it's not working anyway we'll
also break down what republicans need to
be doing and just how dangerous and how
disastrous it would be
to be you know to elect this radical
group of extremists
the bottom line is this you know here we
go again
this is witch hunt 2.0 ukraine okay but
on
human growth hormone and steroids no due
process
again rampant hypocrisy again a wild
conspiracy theories lies a hoax again
and all led by a corrupt they
compromised a coward and congenital liar
his name is adam schiff he's been
hell-bent on
smearing this president now for three
long years
and no matter what lie he has to tell he
will tell no matter how corrupt no
matter what lacking of due process he's
going to let it all happen
now let not your hearts be troubled he
has lied to this country for three
straight years
now we know how this is going to play
out in the end and that is in 358 days
you we the american people we ultimately
get to decide
how this ends and former democratic
mayor of san francisco he actually
summed it up pretty nicely willie brown
writing quote
democrats will spend the next few
precious months acting out a pretend
cliffhanger
to which everyone actually knows the
script and the ending
and come next year trump will have an
impeachment victory and quite possibly
likely i'd say a solid economy the
democrats will have what
absolutely nothing look what senator
lindsey graham said
impeachment in the senate will be dead
on arrival
watch this it's impossible
to bring this case forward in my view
fairly
without us knowing who the whistleblower
is and having a chance to cross-examine
them
about any biases that they may have so
if they don't call the whistleblower in
the house
this thing is dead on arrival in the
senate all right the corrupt congenital
liar shift show trial
this is one big huge
scam hypocrisy on a level that is
breathtaking
now here's why there's no due process
they tried to create the impression of
due process there's no due process
whatsoever
because every single piece of evidence
every rule every witness
called in this whole procedure every
question asked
is at the discretion of that guy that
big liar that congenital liar
which is the exact opposite of what newt
gingrich gave bill clinton in 1998
now adam schiff the congenital liar and
he alone
will have the power to deny any request
from the president or his attorneys
ranking members of the republicans that
are on the committee
they have no real power they have no
real say
this is really a corrupt circus this is
beyond a show trial beyond a kangaroo
court
shift can deny any witness the
opportunity to testify he can prevent
any piece of evidence from being
presented remember how he lied about
having all the evidence all this time
about trump-russia collusion
he lied about robert mueller's findings
he lied about the president's phone call
with ukraine
even fabricating the entire transcript
and then he lied about his involvement
with the
hearsay non-whistleblower whistleblower
and despite shift denying having
any contact with this individual well
we've learned that in fact his
office had been quote closely advising
the whistleblower before he even filed a
complaint
which brings us to our second point and
that is that man running this show trial
starting tomorrow publicly
is totally compromised he is a material
witness in the charade
in a case he has now appointed himself
judge jury and executioner
and then third schiff is radical extreme
socialist base
and the mob in the media none of them
are impartial actors that really care
about truth and justice just the
opposite
this is a and has been from the get-go a
political hit
job and we know this because they've
been planning this before the president
was even sworn in take a look at this
if he takes the risk of going to trial
and he's convicted that could be seen as
an impeachable offense
if trump were caught on a video camera
snorting cocaine in the white house
maybe with one of his children
there was at least a chance he'd be
impeached there are tools
that congress has i don't see how that
wouldn't be an impeachable offense
impeachable offense
and beachbody
grounds for impeachment impeachables
compensable offense impeachment
all of that may be impeachable that's an
impeachable offense impeachable offense
impeachable offense impeachment
impeachment and peaceful offense grounds
for impeachment impeachable grounds for
impeachment
impeachment impeachable offense
impeachment impeachment impeachable
we're going to go in there we're going
to impeach the impeachables
if that's not impeachable i don't know
what is the president shall be removed
from office on impeachment
is it impeachable 100 percent is
impeachable
guilty of high crimes and misdemeanors
grounds for
impeachment talk of impeachment none of
us came to congress to impeach a
president
but now we have to do our duty now after
the russia
hoax conspiracy theory lies blew up in
their faces four separate investigation
fbi nothing house intel nothing
bipartisan senate committee nothing
mueller nothing
all right we won't waste three more
years we'll go to a backup plan
involving president trump this phone
call with ukraine
there are eight examples of quid pro
quo's we were told
yeah that's a lie too and you know what
it just shows where their mind is set is
at at this time now
while the public involved in this we got
the transcript of the president's
call no quid pro quo no misconduct
whatsoever
just on the other hand the faith the
president doing his job
faithfully executing the laws of this
land
and the current front-runner the
democratic party and that would be
creepy crazy
uncle joe biden he is on tape
just like the only russian interference
was hillary's bought and paid for
dossier oh the only quid pro quo is joe
biden
on tape bragging about shaking down
the very same country of ukraine with
a real billion dollars of tax money we
saw it on tape
he's bragging telling the country of
ukraine you have six hours to fire your
top prosecutor
well that he was told was investigating
his zero
zero none experienced son the son who
has paid
millions fire the prosecutor in six
hours
you get a billion you don't fire the
prosecutor
you don't get a billion well son of a
bee they fired him
and at the very same time that very same
prosecutor
yep we now know was investigating his
son hunter
zero experience hunter along with
hunter's company
the ukrainian oil and gas giant barisma
holdings
now no experienced hunter no experience
in oil gas
energy or in ukraine so now why
would somebody with no experience be
paid millions and millions of dollars
by a company in ukraine when his father
is a vice president
in charge of the obama administration's
policies in ukraine
great question and according to a brand
new report from the new york times
even biden's own aides were concerned
about hunter's ukrainian business
dealings quote
they were so worried about the optics
that they enlisted state department
officials
to gather facts to determine how to
handle the story
so let's recap you got a congenital
compromise
fact witness liar leading this circus
show trial
against a duly elected president of the
united states that he
personally has been trying to get rid of
for three years
lying about for three years he's
offering no due process
all while the president's political
opponent is on camera bragging
about the very thing that we're all
supposed to be upset about in the exact
same country
for which president trump is wrongfully
accused you can't make this up
read the transcript president trump was
rightly performing
his constitutional sworn duty that's
right
he is sworn to uphold at the laws of
this land and by the way we have an
agreement with ukraine in terms of
cooperation
on criminal matters and election
interference with ukraine we know
happened
by the way when did we stop caring about
foreign countries interfering in our
elections
because the same interference detailed
by politico
january 11 2017 detailed
how a real dnc operative working with
the ukrainian
embassy trying to dig up dirt to smear
donald trump and his associates
uh bolstering the clinton campaign they
actually happened
and by the way there was a court
decision in ukraine that actually told
that story as well
there's real collusion just like the
real
clinton bought and paid for russian
dossier there really was russian
interference
and now we see ukrainian interference to
help hillary
and for good measure president trump is
planning planning now to release
a transcript of another call with
ukraine which i think is a great idea
and should be a new standard because
it's time to demand
that all of joe biden's transcripts of
all of his phone calls with ukraine
be made public and i think while we're
at it i'd like to see president obama's
transcripts with the country of russia
and vladimir putin after he promised to
medvedev
more flexibility after my election and
let's also see the transcripts perhaps
from obama's conversations
with iranian leaders in the lead-up to
him giving the hate america mueller's of
iran
150 billion dollars of our cash and
other currency
after all we have to make sure there's
no no quid pro quos
now it's right now time for republicans
to get tough
senate republicans need to pay attention
we all know schiff is going to veto
pretty much
any and all witnesses that will hamper
his
narrative his hopes is witch hunt in the
house
so republicans have the power in the
senate that means you have the power to
subpoena people
there are witnesses that need to be
subpoenaed immediately
and i would start with the
non-whistleblower whistleblower whose
complaint was based totally on hearsay
we know he was close to joe biden we
know he's a democratic activist
we know he had contact with schiff's
office before he filed the complaint
now he needs to answer some important
questions where did you get your
information
did chip's office help write the
complaint did they advise you to get an
attorney
go to the inspector general uh what are
your ties to john brennan your former
boss
what was the nature of your relationship
with joe biden in his campaign
did you collude with anybody in schiff's
office
by the way we should also bring in adam
schiff and schiff's office
he should have to answer questions and
by the way members of his staff
by the way they don't have privilege
they'd have to show up
they can be subpoenaed and they can all
be put under oath in the u.s senate
they need to answer for their
involvement with the phony whistleblower
it's also time to put hunter biden under
oath
did he speak with his father about his
ukrainian business deals
their statements we already know and
have pointed out are in conflict with
each other
we know the new york times tipped off
joe biden that his son was being
investigated
by the prosecutor in ukraine so that
would mean
joe well he too should be subpoenaed
like adam schiff and hunter biden should
be subpoenaed like the whistleblower
should be subpoenaed
by the way what did hunter say to his
father did he ask for favors
did hunter biden know that barisma
paying him
millions for no experience was in fact
using his name to get the obama state
department
to do favors for barisma holdings now
the next person who would need to go
under oath
is former vice president yep joe biden
himself he should be subpoenaed
what did he really know when when did he
know that his son was being investigated
how many people warned him his son was
being investigated when was he aware
that the ukrainian prosecutor
that he got fired was investigating his
son
and how many times was he told his son
was in fact investigated
what role did his son play in u.s policy
in ukraine if any
and next hunter's business partner
fellow barista board member devin archer
what did he say to vice president biden
about barrissman
they have a picture of them all golfing
together also nelly orr needs to be
forced to testify
under oath in the u.s senate she worked
for fusion gps
along with christopher steele her
husband the fourth ranking
highest member of the doj what was her
role in proliferating
russian misinformation throughout the
highest levels of government
what did she get from ukraine also we
need to bring in
well former dnc contractor
operative alexandra chalupa remember
politico in january 2017 detailed her
efforts
to meet with ukrainians in the ukrainian
embassy did she
collude on behalf of the dnc and hillary
clinton
did they actually get dirt from ukraine
so did she enlist the efforts of this
foreign government
on hillary clinton's behalf who ordered
her to do it
also ambassador volcker must be called
to answer questions under oath as well
did he have any direct evidence of aid
to ukraine being tied to a political
campaign
was the aid actually delivered do you
think corruption in ukraine is a
legitimate concern for a president of
the united states
everything that you witnessed this week
is
all about the upcoming election the
senate republicans have the power
to bring in all of these people and they
should issue those subpoenas
they've got to reject house democrats
that are corrupt
hypocritical abusing their power
dividing the country
and really they need to get to the truth
in the senate
the truth about the fake whistleblower
who clearly had a political agenda
the truth about the compromise corrupt
adam schiff the truth about
quid pro quo joe it's time to expose
this witch hunt for what it is
now we'll have more of my monologue in
just a minute including an important
preview of the upcoming fisa abuse
report we expect one week from today